alright let's go ahead and get started
so welcome everybody my name is Scott
and today I'm gonna be talking to you
about blazer which is C sharp running in
the browser on top of web assembly so
before we get too deep into things I
just want to talk about the audience I
kind of had in mind when I made this in
case this doesn't sound like something
for you you can go find another talk
so mostly I've targeted dotnet
developers and I kind of mentioned this
earlier but how many people have done
net at some point like most the room as
well as if you're just a JavaScript
developer somebody doesn't know any net
I think you'll also get something out of
this talk as well however I did kind of
target this mostly for dotnet developers
but I think you'll also pick something
up as well if you're just interested in
web assembly so what we're going to talk
about today we're gonna talk about what
is web assembly what is blazer like
what's the difference between those two
I'll do demos all throughout and I'll
probably hold off questions until the
end if that's cool with everybody
because for a couple of reasons one this
talk gets over at 640 and everybody
everybody's probably gonna be hungry so
I want to get everybody out as fast as
possible plus when I've done this talk
before and taking questions I said a lot
of times like hey I'm gonna cover that
because this topic generates a lot of
questions so hopefully I'll hit hit most
of your questions but if not I'll come
up afterwards and I'll be happy to
answer any questions that you might have
so what I hope you get out of this is
not to be some sort of blazer experts
I do think you will pick up some tips on
how to get blazer working on your own
however what I hope you get out of this
is you can just differentiate what is
blazer and what is webassembly
and then just get excited for the future
and the possibilities that those two
each brings together so Who am I I'm a
software consultant at a company called
lean techniques primarily dotnet and
JavaScript developer I'm a big react
fanboy so what I'm doing right now is
writing react every day at the client
I'm at I
actually enjoy writing JavaScript I know
some people don't like writing
JavaScript however I do enjoy your
running JavaScript I blog and then I'm
also the I have made some blazer
snippets for vs code anybody use that a
chance nobody just me and my parents
still okay that's cool alright so before
we get into blazer and webassembly let's
just like level set as to what the
current state of the spa front-end is so
let's say you get clearance to write a
new spa application you have a few
different decisions to make one of the
first ones you have to decide is what
language are you going to use are you
going to use the latest JavaScript are
you gonna use typescript Flow reason Elm
closure Jas whatever it is that's kind
of the first decision you have to make
and then you have to decide all right
what framework am I going to use am I
gonna use react angular View amber
really a latest hotness felt that just
came out or just like straight-up
vanilla Jas which by the end of it
you'll probably end up creating your own
framework so maybe not that one so much
and then you got to pick your tool chain
am I gonna use webpack am I gonna use
babble am I gonna use es lint
okay cool you're gonna use es lint now
like what configuration are you gonna
use like Airbnb Google common like all
these different decisions that you have
to make when you're starting on the spa
front-end and was anybody in curry
houses talk in this room right before
this painful cool so he has a
Pluralsight course where he is talking
about building a JavaScript development
environment where he outlines all these
different choices that you have to make
when you're building a JavaScript
development environment and I would
actually argue that this isn't an
extensive list I would argue you
probably have to make you more decisions
than this because at the end of the day
the day you have to deal with JavaScript
if you're doing a spa front-end vbscript
was like a thing for like maybe a half
second flash was there for a little
while silver lights and Steve Jobs came
in and killed them both and now we
pretty much are left with just dealing
with JavaScript at the end of
day so what problems does this create
well whether you are a JavaScript fanboy
or not you have to admit there's a bunch
of people out there who don't like
JavaScript they come from a statically
typed language like C sharp Java
whatever it is and they don't like the
fact that JavaScript like you might have
a typo but you don't know until you go
to run your app unless you're writing
tests of course because everybody's
writing tests right right uncomfortable
smiles all right so but then when your
app blows up at runtime whereas in one
of those other statically typed
languages the compiler yells at you and
says hey you made a typo there and
here's the line number and you need to
go fix it the JavaScript ecosystem as
well just has more integration or more
stitching together and less integration
so you got to pull these different
pieces together yourself browser
supports a little sketchy sometimes and
there's tools yet around that moves
really fast and then NPM and the know
modules older also gets some hate as
well as well as something I don't think
is talked about enough is spas are just
more expensive to maintain in general
reason being then like your traditional
server rendered app reason being you
either have a front-end team and a
back-end team that you have to like have
these separate responsibilities or you
have to train up your team to be full
stack which I think these days is just
really hard to keep up with for instance
if you're on the dotnet space keeping up
with all the asp.net core stuff and then
keeping up with what's happening now and
react and or angular or whatever it is I
think it's just really difficult to do
that without spending some extra time on
your own which is this kind of a bummer
having to do it outside of work also
when you're using like c-sharp with spa
front-end you end up with this
disconnect where you want to share code
but you can't because like validation
logic for instance like say you have
summer say you're filling out a form and
you have some required fields but
they're only required under certain
circumstances you
share the logic that you have on the
server with your clients but you really
can't because there are two different
languages so you have a choice of all
right now I got to write in JavaScript
and I got to write it and C sharp or you
just write in c-sharp and let the server
take that hit as well as you get like no
IDE help when you do like an ajax call
right so if you're using fetch
Axios jquery whatever it is and let's
say you're getting back a customer and
you're like alright I need the job of
that customer object I'm getting back
but I don't remember if I call that job
or occupation so now I got to go look
and see what I called that unless you
bring in like yet another tool like RFQ
l or something that keeps your
typescript models and sync with your
c-sharp models but again that's yet
another tool you have to bring into your
tool chain so now that we talked about
kind of the current state of the spa
front-end let's talk about web assembly
or wisdom which is like a way funner
thing to say than dotnet like.net kind
of sucks to say to be honest but
likewise 'm is fun to say i just saying
wisdom anyway so as 'm is a low-level
binary format language that can be run
in modern browsers that runs at near
native speeds so what does that mean
well unless you're super hardcore you're
probably not going to be writing in web
assembly like mere mortals like me are
probably gonna just be writing in
something else like c-sharp or Java or
whatever it is and then you're gonna
compile down to web assembly and so web
assembly is a browser standard that most
of the modern browsers have implemented
and it gives you this little like
sandbox for you to run your code at
near-native speeds so in theory your web
assembly code can run faster than your
JavaScript code but they don't re int
all of the Dom API s or anything in web
assembly they give you like these little
things that you can do with web assembly
and you can also shell out to JavaScript
it will actually take a look at that
here in a second so it's its own little
sandbox in its own little island
within the browser but what this means
is there's no more JavaScript monopoly
it means you have a choice now you can
pick the language that you want as long
as it compiles to the web assembly you
can write it write a spa application in
that language
and we'll take a look at that here in a
little bit so you may have a question
now I said it's a browser standard so
you may think yourself alright cool
it's probably only in chrome nothing
else right well the good news is it's in
all modern browsers other than Opera
Mini which whatever let's just take that
out for a second
other than IE 11 which obviously I 11
all Microsoft support is going towards
edge so they're not going to implement
that so you you're probably like oh
sweet let me pack up my bags cuz I'm in
the enterprise that's like all my users
or maybe all my users are like 70 plus
or something and so they just use
whatever comes with Windows so they use
IE well the good news is you can
actually polyfill wasm with something
called Azzam j/s so you can get your web
assembly working on ie 11 and everything
works just fine now little caveat it
will be a little slower because they're
running JavaScript not web assembly but
let's be honest they're not if they're
on IE anyway they're used to things
being slow so no big deal so what is
blazer then which that is the official
logo for sorry it's official icon for
blazer it's not a logo because logo
apparently means like lawyerly things at
Microsoft world so it's an icon that
Microsoft has provided on a logo so
blazer is a dotnet spa framework that's
currently in preview that lets you mix
c-sharp in HTML that runs in the browser
on top of that sandbox web assembly so
you may think to yourself c-sharp in the
browser I've heard this before
isn't this just Silverlight all over
again I see some people smiling and some
tears to
it's it's okay it's a safe place no
again it's not a plug-in model it's a
standard so Steve Jobs he's not gonna
come back from the dead
hopefully and if he does like I he could
kill webassembly like just don't kill me
but it's a standard not a plug-in so you
don't have to worry about this going
away it's been implemented in all those
browsers that we looked at a second ago
so Blaser uses the razor syntax how many
people are familiar with razor or have
done HBO MBC alright cool like
two-thirds the room so use the razor
syntax so for those of you who aren't
familiar with it basically the razor
syntax is just like you write some HTML
and then you want to write some c-sharp
so you write an @ symbol and then you
can start writing C sharp so if you've
done react razor is JSX
but instead of JavaScript in curly
braces you use an @ symbol and write C
sharp but so this is actually where the
name came from is browser plus razor
plus let's just throw an L in there just
make it sound cool and there you get
blaze there and so the icon it has an @
symbol in it as a reference to razor
blazer also uses the component-based
architecture that you may be familiar
with if you've done any spot work lately
react uses this angular view all those
and if you haven't done anything as long
as you know like MVC patterns mvvm
you'll pick it up super quick and I'll
show you that here in a little bit and
blazer runs on top of this thing called
mono how many people know what mono is
cool like half the room two thirds right
so mono is what powers xamarin so it
lets you it's an implementation of
the.net framework so you get the same
system dot whatever api's and it lets
you write like ios and android game our
games apps so it's what powers am ran
under the hood so blazer is kind of like
your UI framework on top so it's like
your asp.net MVC your web forms sorry if
that
give you some traumatic experiences when
I said webforms but so blades are
sitting on top and then you have mono
your run time so that's like your
Donette core your done at framework and
then mono sits on top of web assemblies
so it's blazer on top mono in the middle
and web sembly on bottom on the bottom
and so development of blazer is led by
Steve Sanderson who you can make an
argument kind of started the spar
evolution a little bit because he was
kind of in there early with knockouts so
if you're sitting there thinking like
Microsoft doesn't know anything about
building spa frameworks Steve Sanderson
knows a thing or two about building
client-side applications so if you
followed along with blazer before this
this is a fairly new announcement as
like 3-4 weeks ago so blazer was
experimental but now it's in preview and
because Microsoft likes to come up with
their own words and don't use things
like alpha beta RC I now have the
pleasure of explaining to you what
experimental and preview are so
experimental basically means it's like a
proof of concept right it's something
that they're just experimenting with and
trying to figure out if this is even
viable whereas preview means hey we're
gonna ship this so it's actually coming
whereas experimental was like kind of no
commitment was attached so preview is
kind of like a beta and experimental is
kind of like a pre alpha so they made
the announcement that they are going to
ship client side blazer sometime here in
the future which is pretty awesome
so you may be thinking yourself all
right cool I can write C sharp running
in the browser so what kind of C sharp
can I write well blazer is dotnet
standard 2 compliant which means like 60
70 percent of the.net framework that you
know and love can run in the browser
with a bit of an asterisk so you are
running in sandbox in the browser like
does it make sense for you to just fire
off some emails or like call system do
dot file dot delete and start deleting
people's like C drives
stuff like that probably not so these
throw platform not supported exceptions
but a lot of the api's do make a ton of
sense with writing c-sharp in the
browser and probably the best example is
making an ajax call so making an ajax
call is super close to making an HTTP
client call in c-sharp you have an
endpoint you have some headers you
return some JSON it's really close
together and so when you make an AJAX
call in blazer you make an HTTP client
call and we'll take a look at that here
in a second another like capability of
blazer is you can call c-sharp from
JavaScript and call JavaScript from C
sharp which calling JavaScript from
c-sharp is probably the more interesting
scenario because like I said you can't
do everything in web assembly you can do
in JavaScript so you can write c-sharp
wrappers on top of JavaScript API is to
call things like local storage which
we'll look at here in a minute because
I'm sick of doing slides the payment
request API like anything you can do in
the Dom you can technically write a
c-sharp wrapper on top of it or what's
more likely gonna happen people ship
packages that wrap this stuff so in
theory you can write a spa application
completely in c-sharp and not have to
touch JavaScript and C sharp just Maps
to JavaScript really well so you have a
sink and a weight in JavaScript c-sharp
side that for a little while and a task
and c-sharp is really close to a promise
in JavaScript so that's how they're able
to interact between these two really
easily all right so anybody entered
interested in this so far handful okay I
got the challenge to try and get the
rest of you it's probably like half the
room rest of you I don't know I guess
we'll see see what happens after this
slide so why would you be interested in
Blazer so first thing c-sharp is a
really great language and that's not to
say javascript isn't however I would say
static static types are winning in the
JavaScript community and as evidence of
this of
half of the people who responded to the
npm survey so they write typescript not
javascript which is kind of crazy to
think like half of the people who
consider themselves JavaScript
developers don't actually write
JavaScript like how many people who
consider themselves c-sharp developers
write something that compiles to c-sharp
right
not many so I think this is an
indication that static types are winning
in the JavaScript ecosystem so c-sharp
has that by default another big thing is
performance so the tech and power
benchmarks which kind of measures
independent it's an independent body who
measures web frameworks and a CI core is
number seven on the Tekken power
benchmarks and there's like 10 or 11 and
then congested at the top and these are
like every web framework known to man so
even people's like hobbies and stuff
like that so even not real web servers
are above asp.net core so it's probably
more like no three at number three
number four but where it currently
stands it's eight times faster in the
node one half times faster than Neddie
which is a popular Java 147 times faster
than Django seven times faster than
Kotlin it laps PHP like a million times
over and so on and so forth
and what's more is this is asp.net core
2.2 3.0 they've improved the performance
by over 40% and reduced the memory by
over 90% so I wouldn't be surprised if
they end up number one on that list even
on the not real frameworks so they're
continually investing in performance so
that's another reason why you may be
interested in using c-sharp the other
reason is you can actually share that
validation logic that I mentioned
earlier so like that scenario of
something's required under certain
circumstances you can share that logic
with your front end and your back end as
well as you can share those models that
I mentioned earlier with like your
customer object or customer class and
retrieve those from the client and get
your full intellisense so I'll show that
here in a second
but I think the biggest one is you can
consolidate your front end in your
back-end teams or your full stack team
under one single language you don't have
to learn two different like testing
libraries you don't have to learn two
different HTTP libraries you just learn
how to do it in c-sharp and have it go
all the way down which is really handy
all right so I'm gonna start doing a
demo that's cool with all of you because
I'm sick of talking so if I want to
create a new blazer application I'm just
gonna fire up Visual Studio here I'm
gonna say create new project and you
actually select a speed on that core
application so I'm gonna say next
web application 37 sounds wonderful and
you're gonna get a few different options
oh this whole podium moves that's cool
you have a few different options so you
have blazer asp.net core hosted which
means you have an ASP a core API
back-end you're gonna have just a
straight-up blazer client side app so
like technically you could have blazer
running with a different back-end
different API back-end so you could have
like blazer on the front end with node
on the back end just to like roll rivers
and have JavaScript on the server and
c-sharp on the client and then there's
also this blazer server side which we'll
talk about what that is
and why I'm not a huge fan of it but I'm
gonna mention it anyway so I'm gonna
choose blazer asp.net core hosted
because that's the more interesting one
so what this is going to do is it's
going to create me three different
projects it's going to create me a
client project a server project in a
shared project and you can probably
guess what all three of those do so if I
come over here there's my client project
with all my Blaser code there's my
server project with my controller that
does the API call and then I have a
shared project that has a weather
forecast model in it so if I crack that
open everybody see that that code in the
back looks good all right so
this code is on my API so if I go to my
server project there's the weather
forecast model right there and then
we'll take a look in a second on it
running client-side as well when we
consume it but before we go too deep
into the code let's just look at what
this application is doing because I
think it might make more sense if we
look at what it's doing before we look
at the code so we just have some normal
markup here this piece is a little
interesting and we'll take a look at why
because it looks super lame right now
but if I go to this counter component
you can click the button and it
increments and you keep clicking and it
keeps increment and that's Blaser so see
you guys have fun at poop comp no not
really but if you watch when I go to
this fetch data this is actually going
to do an API call and you'll see a
loading screen a little loading message
happen for a second and then it will
actually do the actual API call so it
kind of shows you how to do some basic
things with Blaser out of the box so
let's go ahead and start looking at the
code for this so if I go to the client
project and go to so everything's under
slash pages by default and all of the
Blazer files have a dot raiser extension
this used to be dot CS HTML which if you
come from the HP MVC background that'll
be very familiar to you but they changed
it to dot raiser because it lets you get
even better intellisense and some better
tooling and stuff like that so they've
made that change but that's not a huge
deal so let's crack open sorry let's
crack open the counter counter component
so you give it this page directive and
then say this is available at slash
counter which is something I forgot to
call out so if I come back to the code
you notice I'm at slash counter got a
home goes to home but a fetch data it
changes it fetch data so Blaser gives
you client side routing out of the box
and so this is saying hey this
components available at slash counter
some standard markup here
and then here's where things start to
get a little interesting so it says hey
here's the current count and it's
referencing this c-sharp here that says
at current count which if you go to this
functions block here you'll see on line
10 there's an a current count variable
that starts at zero and then on this
button there's an on click that calls a
c-sharp method called increment counts
and all it does is current count plus
plus so a pretty simple code pretty
self-explanatory what all that does so
let's look at a more interesting
scenario let's look at an API call so
again I have the page directive and the
route saying this is Vale bot slash
fetch data I using that just brings in a
namespace so for those of you from
JavaScript this is like an import and
then I'm saying inject me an HTTP client
that's pre-configured to start hitting
my API and we'll take a look at how we
use this HTTP variable in a second some
boring markup and then says if forecast
is null show that loading thing that we
saw for two seconds or for now even
second two seconds couple seconds
otherwise loop over all the data and
drop this into a table so if you've done
asp.net MVC this should look really
really familiar to you and again we've
got an app functions block where we've
got some of our dynamic code that's
running client-side and here's that
forecast variable we were looking at
earlier and then Blaser gives you these
events you can subscribe to so if you
come from a react background on a knit
async is like component didn't mount and
you can say hey set my forecast to this
HTTP call so that HTTP client I injected
earlier get some JSON back and then cast
it to an array of weather forecasts and
hit this API at this endpoint so this
lets me get that strongly typed in so if
I come over here to forecast and type
type in here I get that nice
intellisense so imagine doing this in
JavaScript if you're using some sort of
you know fetch or xeo soar just jQuery
to make this
Ajax call you wouldn't get this
intellisense like you would with blazer
so that's pretty cool that you get that
out of the box and so that is the fetch
data component so let's look at the
homepage cuz I said that was a little
more interesting so again it's saying
and this is available out the route
here's some markup and then there's a
survey prompt tag which I'm sure most of
you can see where this is going
Blazer this is an actual blazer
component and from the parent component
I'm able to change the behavior by
passing it a title so that how is blazar
working for you matches up to these this
house blaze are working for you so I
could change what that title is by
passing something different into it
so let's just go ahead and make our own
component so I'm gonna make an alert
component how many people have done
bootstrap just bootstrap the CSS
framework almost the room
alright so bootstrap has the concept of
alerts and they have all sorts of
different types of alerts so you can
have like alert - danger for dark red
wine or - info for blue one that kind of
thing and in fact that survey prompt
this is an alert right here it's just a
call-out it's that dark grey background
but I want all my alerts to look the
same so I'm just gonna make aids add an
ad here I'm just gonna make my own alert
component so if I make an enum so I'm
just gonna call this alert types and
just say info and warning it's fine for
now and how you pass in that title that
you saw earlier is you make a variable
or a property that you decorate with a
parameter attribute and that lets
somebody change it downstream so I can
just say hey I want an alert type and so
this means somebody upstream can say
whether they want an info or warning
alert types so if I make a get CSS class
method here and I'll just switch on
alert type I'm gonna say hey when it's
an info one return
alert - info copy/paste like a good
programmer and say warning is going to
return alert - warning and then the
default I'm just going to throw an
exception because you did something
crazy so then I can drop that get CSS
class right here and just say hey based
on whatever they passed in change what
the alert is but the problem is like I
want to change like some of this dynamic
content here but I want to pass in like
my own HTML
well blazer gives you a way to do that
by again taking a parameter and using
something called a render fragment so
I'm just going to call this child
content and I'll just drop that child
content right here so what this is gonna
do is upstream so I'm gonna save this
cuz that's probably important I'm going
to get rid of the survey prompt here and
just say hey I want to alert and I
didn't even build or anything and I'm
are getting Intel sense if I could stop
moving for a half second already getting
Intel sense for that alert component
that I created what's more I'm also
getting intellisense for the parameter
that I just gave it so hey I said hey
this is an alert type and I get full
intellisense for that so now I'm gonna
have to bring in the whole namespace
here or I could just bring in a using
statement but I'll just give it the
whole namespace so again I'm getting the
full intellisense saying hey this is a
certain kind of alert type so I'm gonna
say hey this is an info zoom out and now
here's where I want to pass that dynamic
HTML so I can pass in and say hello
NDC and I'll just save and rebuild here
and what should happen is I should have
a alert with a dark red or dark blue
background and some content in the
middle that says hello NDC I say MBC
earlier and NDC and so that's what I so
that's what I get so if I want to change
this to warning I can just just switch
that and now my background of my alerts
will be dark yellow or light yellow
so what this is so those of you ever
done react or angular this will feel
really familiar but you can actually
make these components and make some
common component library that all of
your applications that your company use
so all of your alerts look the same so
if you want to make dismissible alerts
like with a little X there that lets you
close it out you could totally do that
so I showed you kind of like hello world
on blazer some components looked at
dependency injection with the HTTP
clients and we looked at some sharing
logic between the two so if I were you I
would probably have some random
questions so I'm just gonna hit those
random questions now so mate you may
think to yourself alright cool donek or
our don''t framework is like 80 100
Meg's so reloading 80 or hundred Meg in
the browser the answer is no we're
loading 2.4 megabytes which still is not
stellar but just to prove to you I will
go to the network tab here and disable
my cache I could click and go ahead and
refresh and you can see there it's 2.4
Meg's which some of this is like
bootstrap and stuff but it's right
around 2.3 2.4 Meg's what's interesting
here is I scroll up you'll notice I'm
actually loading DLLs I'll talk about
why that is in a second but 2.4 Meg's
obviously is an ideal but a lot of
people can get away with that to be
honest like if you're on an internal
application you can probably get away
with that but they're gonna make it
they're gonna keep improving this
because they know this isn't great so
you may ask yourself are it do wasm
files cache and do those dll's that we
saw cache just like regular javascript
files and the answer is yes so if I
enable my cache and look back down here
you can see it's 12 K so you pay that
cost once and then you're good to go
from that point out that point on so how
does it work under the hood oops
zoom out
so how does blazar work so at dev time
so like when I'm making those changes of
this components it generates me dll's on
the fly and those dll's are loaded in
the browser and read from the mono
runtime which is actually compiled the
full web assembly so it's loading your
dll's on the browser which is a little
like trippy as is this whole thing and
then mono reads it on the fly and loads
your dll's for you and then mono talks
to the browser api's where they want to
get to in the future is you take your
dll's and you further compile them down
to wasm files which improves performance
but it's a little slower to like when
you're Devon it's a little slower to do
that because now you've got another
compilation step so what they're
thinking is like a dev time they'll be
like on the left side here and then when
you go to publish it'll generate you add
some files so that your code executes a
little faster well they're still working
on that so the next question you may ask
yourself is why mono and why not dotnet
core like isn't dotnet core the latest
hotness well the reason is mono is
already client-side folk or client-side
focused so mono pond powers amber and it
powers unity for making games
whereas dotnet core is kind of more
server-side focused and kind of in
anticipates being run like I know on an
OS or something like that
and mono has already developed for like
really constrained platforms like TVs
watches ps4 that kind of thing so they
kind of just like got it working first
it is a big thing but they also have a
linker which is like trims out the dll's
you're not using because they need that
for xamarin to try and reduce
installation size and I can show you
that working right down here so right
here in Visual Studio zoom in you can
see it's deleting the assemblies you're
not using so it's saying hey you're not
using system component model dot
composition let me go ahead and delete
that out but I am using system not net
HTP for HP client so let me go ahead and
keep that in so this is how you get that
8100 Meg framework down to 2 point 4
Meg's like I said they just kind of got
it working here first long-term like
this is the fun part about giving a talk
right when Microsoft builds going on is
they release new things so I got a scan
real quick like what announcements did
they make and now I got to go update my
slides so people heard of done at 5:00
that just got announced this week in
full so donít 5 is a unified framework
for dotnet core mono and full framework
so what you can think of it as is
they're gonna take dotnet core and take
in pieces of mono and make like the part
where mono like trims things out and can
run on unique platforms they're gonna
take the best of that and put it in
dotnet core and maybe they'll take
something out of full framework to I
don't know I don't know if there's
anything worthwhile there but this will
give you a single run time to target
mobile web and desktops so no longer do
you have to worry about oh am I using
mono or Dona core you'll just use da net
5 so the name da net core will kind of
go away there'd still be asp.net core
but the name
da net core will kind of go away and the
reason why they chose 5 was because
Microsoft is historically really bad at
versioning and this is no different so
currently they're on done at core 3.0 or
their it's in preview right now and they
have dotnet framework which is like four
point eight four point six all that kind
of stuff so they chose five because five
is higher than four for dotnet framework
and because five is higher than three so
they're kind of pulling the angular move
where angular went from like two to four
for similar issue reasons they are
calling gonna call this future dotnet 5
and this is coming out in November 2020
which probably means sometime mid 2021
because that's kind of how Microsoft
rules oh this is recorded isn't it
lovely all right
uh totally not going to be an MVP
anytime soon
that's cool so what I'm going to show
you next is writing c-sharp and
interacting with local storage which is
a JavaScript only API so if I run this
application here is anybody familiar
with to do MVC infull yep so what this
is is just a simple to do app that lets
you people write in their framework of
choice and they can compare and contrast
it so I wrote one for blazer so it's
really fancy you say like what tasks you
want to do and then you can like check
them off and delete them really fancy
but what's cool is when i refresh my
tasks stayed right there even if I check
them off they refresh and they stay
right there
now how did that happen well I am using
something called local storage with such
which lets you store some data in the
browser so you probably don't want to do
this for anything sensitive but for
tasks it's perfectly fine so I'm storing
some local storage here some data and
local storage here and all it is is a
key and a value both strings but if I
come over here to my code and I scroll
up you'll see there is no JavaScript
whatsoever here even though I'm
interacting with JavaScript and the
reason is I've wrapped it in this local
storage class so you can kind of think
of like people are gonna start shipping
you get packages that kind of wrap
common JavaScript things you want to do
and you can just write C sharp and not
have to worry about JavaScript and not
have to potentially write JavaScript for
making a blazer application is anybody
interested in not writing JavaScript to
make a spa front-end alright like half
the room two thirds the room cool so
that's what that demo showing is
technically you can just stay in your
little c-sharp world and not have to
worry about JavaScript ever again which
is pretty cool all right so what else
can we do with Blazer so the cool thing
is Blazers component model is completely
decoupled from the browser because
turns out Steve Sanderson and Microsoft
are pretty smart people so this means
you can run blazer on something called
electron people familiar with electron
and alright like half the room so
electron is a cross-platform desktop
framework that lets you like use web
technologies and have a desktop
application run on like Windows Mac and
Linux
it's what BS code is built on top of the
atom editor like the slack app as well
and so that this gives you the like
theory of write once run anywhere which
is usually alive but that's okay I'll
continue to perpetuate that I guess so
they have a proof concept of running
blazer on top of dotnet core on top of
electron like this wasn't like crazy
enough so you get the full access to the
debugger and Visual Studio you're
running on dotnet core instead of mono
which in the future that don''t 5 thing
we'll figure that out anyway and then
you have access to the native desktop
API so let's just go ahead and look at
laser on electron so I'm just gonna go
ahead and run the app here and to zoom
in and prove I have a desktop app here
here's the black Tron I guess is what
it's called blacktron sample running my
desktop application and surprise
surprise it's the exact same application
or you can click and increment call
fetch data and so on and so forth so in
theory this means you can write a single
application for a client-side blazer and
a single application to also run on the
desktop we have the few caveats that
maybe on the desktop you want access to
desktop II things like a clipboard
deleting people C drives you know that
kind of thing whatever you want to do as
long as they have access from their user
you can do in the desktop so what else
can we do with blazer so you can
actually run blazer running fully on the
server and so this is like it feels
client-side but actually all of the
state is managed on the server and then
those changes are streamed over signal
are through WebSockets back to
the browser why would you want to do
this it's a smaller bundle size so it's
only 400 said of to 2.4 Meg's your code
now runs on the.net core server not
client-side and so you have no
constraints and you have the full
debugger in vs why not
obviously it puts more load on your
server and currently it does not support
disconnects very well either so let's go
ahead and look at blazer on the server
so when you did when I did file new
application there's that blazer server
side option and so that's what this is
here so it's the same exact application
we saw earlier so I can click I can
fetch data that kind of thing but it's
round-tripping to the server every time
so when I click round trips to the
server server streams back the data and
says oh you call the click action let me
just send you this little piece of
information that you need to update back
down to the client and then it updates
that to a1 so if we take a look at the
network tab here and refresh we can go
to the web sockets open up this
WebSockets move this up a little bit and
so when I click loops if I click you can
see like this message round-trips back
to the server so I'll keep clicking and
you can see maybe not be able to see
very well but the data is round-tripping
back to the server so that's also an
option for Blaser so some other people
are getting really interested in Blaser
right now and those are the normal
suspects of their party component
libraries so people like TELRIC people
like sync fusion people like DevExpress
and TELRIC actually released 1.0 of
their components like last week so
they're getting going all in on Blaser
as well so what's the current status of
Blaser then so I can tell you what is
there currently so we have the component
model that I showed earlier we have
routing we have layouts which I didn't
really go over but that's just like MVC
layouts and just kind of like the outer
shell of your
application dependency injection calling
javascript from c-sharp that i showed
earlier with the local storage demo you
can actually share components between
projects so you can get that consistent
look and feel across all of your
different applications you can debug
c-sharp in Chrome which is a little like
but you can't do it in vs quite yet but
they're working on it you new forms and
validation so the normal data anotation
stuff you can do with blazer as well it
has a full visual studio support and
some vs code and I know they're working
on Visual Studio for Mac as well and you
can run blazer server side and on
electron and they're also working on
getting server-side rendering to work
which if you've done spas you may be
familiar with that term so that's like
getting where when you run a blazer app
it says that loading screen for a second
basically it could do all that logic on
the server and stream that down to the
client so you have no loading you get
like an initial quick initial paint and
then blazer picks it up from there so
they're really close on that I try to
get that working but it's like pulling
in pull requests and branches and it was
a little crazy and I'm already running
like preview stuff so I figured that
probably was a really bad idea anyway
but what's coming they want to get
better tooling they want to get hot
reloading so like you save and your
browser Auto refreshes they're working
on the head of time compilation so that
the compiling the DLL is down to Azzam
files they want to get that bundle size
down smaller they're working on some
authentication authorization work so
detecting whether or not you have the
right claims or roles whether you're
logged in or not they're getting that
working as well and they'll probably
ship that in the next month or two and
then they also want to get debugging in
full visual studio which is really close
to working as well so if we call back to
Cori houses decision tree that you have
to make when you make a JavaScript
application it turns out when you leave
when you use blazer a lot of these just
kind of fade away because they're just
not applicable and the remainder of
that are left you've probably already
made on the back end
things like what testing library are you
using you're probably going to keep
using X unit m/s test and unit or my
favorite end users that kind of thing
and so you only have one set of tools to
worry about and you don't have to learn
how do I test react how do I test
angular and how do I test my c-sharp
back-end you just have to worry about
how do I test c-sharp and everything
else is a lot easier to maintain so if
this is the current state of the spa
front-end maybe the future state and I
will say besides JavaScript so don't
come yelling at me
I'm not saying Java scripts going away
I'm saying besides those previous
choices maybe you have more options so
you can pick whether you want to use
c-sharp Java Python rust Go C++ and some
sick person made COBOL running on web
assembly because I I don't know they'd
like inflicting pain on the world I
guess I don't know but then you get
sorry if anybody's a COBOL fan here pays
well because not many people know it
anymore but then you can pick your
framework that you want so do you want
blazer or something called uno which is
a way where you can run zamel and have
it run client side so if you more like
the more Silverlight sam'l model you can
pick up something called uno or we you
can bring in something called we which
is a community project to run c-sharp on
top of web assembly or one of these
other languages might come out with
something new
who knows and then you can pick your
tools like maybe they're more integrated
like everything's in Visual Studio or an
IntelliJ or vs code and everything's
more you're not stitching together all
these different things and I would argue
the JavaScript community is kind of
going this way anyway things like create
react app and Euler see a live view CLI
they're kind of realizing that maybe we
should package some of these tools
together so people don't have to set up
all that stuff every single time so in
the future blazer is currently 3.0
preview 5
and client-side blazer as I mentioned
earlier is no longer experimental which
means it will be shipped sometime in the
future but server-side blazer will
actually ship with da net core 3.0 which
would probably come out in the next two
three months not really sure I don't
work at Microsoft so if it's less or
more don't come yelling at me but I'm
gonna guess down at core 3.0 is going to
ship in about two to three months so
that was that webassembly technology I
showed earlier they were gonna actually
ship that you can use that in production
and get Microsoft support which is
pretty cool however I wouldn't bet my
company on blazer just yet we have I
built a few internal tools on top of
blazer and like that dad jokes app that
showed earlier but I would not bet my
company on blazer just yet just because
it's really early it's still preview
technology and all that kind of stuff so
just saying that because if something
happens to blazer I don't want you
coming after me because you bet your
whole company on it and something
happened to it or went away or took
forever to actually release so what I
hope you got out of this is I hope you
think that wisdom is awesome which I
really wish I came up with that but I
saw it on a podcast like that was the
title of the podcast it's a full
disclosure I did not come up with that
but hopefully you think wisdom is
awesome like I do and hopefully you see
the potential of blazer and web assembly
in the future because I think this has a
chance to radically change how we do web
development in the future like if you go
back to the slide where I had all those
JavaScript technologies like how many of
those are around five years ago maybe
half maybe so the web just moves out a
ridiculous pace and I think web assembly
could also insert itself in there and
radically change how we build web apps
one thing you can start thinking about
today is is this code I'm writing okay
to run in the browser so stuff like
validation so say you've got a login
page which has a username and password
and hopefully both are required
hopefully at least Pat like you don't
let anybody log in as any username
and so that's like input validation
right so that's like hey this input
field is required and I don't have to go
check a database or check an API to see
if this field is required I can just do
that all just in pure logic so that can
run perfectly fine client-side but
something like checking if the user is
locked out requires you checking a
database or checking an API or whatever
it is so that's something that's more
domain validation and something you
should maybe put in a separate method or
class or whatever you want to do but
maybe don't put those two things
together because when you go to run that
on Blaser it's going to blow up at you
so maybe you can start thinking about
hey is this code cool to run in the
browser so if you're like okay this
sounds awesome how do I get started
it's kind of awkward right now to be
honest with you but if you google like
blazer getting started it'll give you
these details so you got to download the
dotnet core preview SDK even though a
Visual Studio 2019 is out you have to
run a preview version of Visual Studio
2000 latest blazer extension if you're
using Visual Studio and then also
install the templates at the command
line in the future when this releases
obviously they're just gonna make it you
just downloads one thing and you get all
the things but that's what it is
currently right now so some resources
for you
the official Microsoft documentation
since this is now official Microsoft
product is that blazer dotnet which
laser net jokes are always better when
you explain them is the official
Microsoft documentation so if you want
to get started with blazer all those
steps I just mentioned will be found
right there as well as like the common
things you might want to do in blazed
they're like validation and all that
sort of stuff there's also some
community lead documentation learn -
blazer Nets which kind of goes into some
even deeper scenarios and since this is
the new Microsoft of course the code is
open source out on github and if you're
interested in what other languages are
doing with webassembly
now those are two links that are really
good that kind of show you
hey where's Python add or where's Java
and tells you like the Blazer equivalent
of some of these other languages so
that's also cool to see as well and
these slides are also up at my blog just
my first and last name Scott Sauber comm
so if you want download these you can
feel free that's why I keep them kind of
detailed just so if you're reviewing
back you can see what I said instead of
having to skim through a video or
something like that so we have like
seven minutes although I did say I would
let you guys go for pub Kampf but I
finished a little early so I guess I'll
just take any questions you might have
seem there's at least one maybe not well
three yep yep yep so currently you
cannot debug in Visual Studio using
client-side blazer so sorry the question
was what's the debugging story for
blazer right now so the debugging story
is you can't debug client-side blazer
but a nice little trick that some people
do is you can actually toggle the
server-side blazer really quick so if
you hit an issue you'll see it in the
console so it'll give you like a bunch
of red in the console until you like an
old reference exception which kind of
gives you a clue anyway but you can
actually switch the server-side blazer
real quick and then get full debugging
visual studio and then figure out what
the problem is change it and switch back
to client-side blazer super easily so
it's actually pretty decent and works
pretty well but that's something that
they want to improve obviously and just
get it natively working with visual
studio so you don't have to do that
little bait-and-switch thing thank you
had a question
yep so the question was well bootstrap
ever not be included in the template so
currently it is included in the template
but you can just get rid of all
bootstrap if you want and bring in
whatever CSS you want to do but there I
don't think they have any plans to
remove it out of the template just
because
well like most the room raise their
hands about knowing bootstraps so it's
just a familiar thing for people but you
totally can use blazer with any
front-end technology or front-end CSS
framework or just roll your own any
other questions yep yep yep so the
question was so Blazers not ready for
prime time quite yet
is it ready for hobby projects
essentially without your question so so
I would say it's probably gonna get
released again oh don't work for
Microsoft but I would probably say it's
going to get released in the next six to
twelve months because if you saw that
list of what's not there it's pretty
close of stuff to at least people get
started then you know people can get
started with the 2.4 Meg's and they can
work on it as they go I would say the
biggest hold up is the motto webassembly
run time they're chill trying to iron
out a few kinks out of there so I would
say the next 6 to 12 months they'll
probably release plays or client side
would be my guess but if you've got a
hobby project I would honestly consider
using blazer as long as you're not
planning on going like super big with it
and betting like a company that might be
a little more apprehensive but it's kind
of up to your risk tolerance but we're
using it for some internal dashboards
and works just fine so a few of other
questions yep yep so the question was
should it work with progressive web apps
since its web technology yep absolutely
and that's something that they care a
lot about and they want to make sure
that it works with that so yep
definitely does any other questions is
everybody hungry all right I'll keep you
for the next five minutes then since
right all right everyone all right
thanks everybody and again
[Applause]
and the after parties at PubCon fat
amsterdam barn hall and again slides are
on my blog if you're interested